the final game of the series tony
gonzalon takes the ball for the dodgers
against merrill kelly of the
diamondbacks and godzilla coming off his
best start so far yeah he's throwing the
ball real well you worried about his
shoulder early on now they're starting
to extend him we might see him out there
for almost 90 pitches today
let's hit hard and through into right
lead off single for rojas good start for
the d-backs
there goes the runner pitches inside
throw from smith
strikes out walker with a high fast ball
to finish off the scoreless first
and the dodgers on the heels of the
22-run output
come to bed on this sunday afternoon
after this
and the right-hander merrill kelly your
d-back starter today
he leads all diamondbacks starting
pitchers in wins strikeouts and innings
pitched
beds at 2 49. 12 home runs he knocked in
37.
crushes this ball in the air to left
center varsity's going
back at the wall
[Applause]
same story one nothing nine home runs in
the last 24 hours and nine
catches from fans oh two from kelly
bellinger reaches out pulls it into the
shift caught by escobar
that's the fastball and knocks it the
other way it's a base in for renick to
start the second
good grinding at bat that time by joshua
fouled off a number of pitches until
eventually he got something he could
handle up and out over the plate
on a 2-2 he's down swinging at an
elevated
splitter on the 20th pitch at the end
godzilla gets the first out
chops one to straight away short for
gavin locks and that'll do it for the
bottom box in the second
right at escobar they get one and they
turn the double play
[Applause]
there's one on the ground backhanded by
rojas tough play from shortstop
and they got him drojas with a lovely
play they get out of the second
yet another one too this one finishes
him off with the curveball
he's only thrown four of those over his
last four starts
got him with the slider that works a
little bit like a cutter right there and
on the hands
two gone on back to back k's
got
and he's two for two back-to-back
multi-hit games for the first time in
more than two months
swing and a miss four strikeout over the
last five hitters for gonsol and his
sixth total
two outs in the fourth and the banner is
steven vogt
vote did miss that one drives it deep to
right field stephen vogt
has tied the ball game that one they
didn't miss that's the fifth for steven
and it's one to one
just another two weeks fastball right by
him that's the first strikeout today for
merrill county
and this one's looking pretty good too
two strikeouts in the inning a one two
three fourth
after four we're tied at one
[Music]
rojos gets into one and drives it toward
the right field corner
one hops the wall chance to take the
lead for josh van meter
squid shot gets through here comes rojas
no throw it's cut off d-backs have the
lead van meter is
out at second but the run is home and
it's 2-1 diamondbacks
with answered with a shutdown 1-2-3 home
half let's see if he can do the same
in the fifth now holding that 2-1 lead
1-2 on chris taylor
a rocket to third edwardo escobar
wow
this whole one from merrill kelly pokes
it off the end of the bat down the line
to right
reddick will not get there and it sinks
[Music]
[Applause]
got him to chase that one merrill gets
strikeout number three and out number
two in the fifth
nice high hop at first merrill covers
and he's out of the fifth
proceeded to lose 24 consecutive road
games after that
strike three call besia feeling froggy
96 to the outside edge in a 10 pitch
one two three six
dodgers down one in the sixth is muncie
pulls one into right for a base head
pass walker
deciding to cut it off his runner muncie
tugging for two
he's got a double the time running
scoring position
i think merrell might be hurt well
something's wrong with meryl kelly
yeah he's not looking good he is walking
around the mound very gingerly
something's not right and he's done
something's wrong and merrill has to
leave the game
this is the one just before the double
right there just kind of awkwardly came
off the first base side of the mound
took a little extra time before throwing
the next pitch
kind of looked into the dugout
now the next pitch is the double into
right and that's when merrill kind of
started circling
around the back of the mound after he
sort of jogged over to cover third
[Applause]
[Music]
territory to back up a play a third if
there was a play at third base
steve you know again we'll take it as a
good sign that he's not
immediately receiving any treatment ken
crenshaw is there
now brett to gus trying to do the same
in the sixth
hellinger sends it to center varsha one
more time
marshall is over two fielders choice oh
one pitch
and the ball hit into left center hit it
pretty well
back on it goes bellinger at the wall
gone
opposite field home run for dalton
varshall
and the diamondbacks take a 4-1 lead two
runs off
alexander on a 4-1 diamondback advantage
backhand turner at third takes it to the
bag and ends the inning
arizona gets two bickford comes on and
strands two
he's stretching a 4-1 game
swinging a miss and joe mantiply
gets him out of the seventh inning he
strikes out pujols we hit the eighth
with a 4-1 lead
smacks one through the right side base
foot and just like that
the time run comes up in the eighth on
mookie bet's third hit of the afternoon
nobody out eighth denny
[Applause]
swings away at the first stretch and
collects another
[Applause]
they've got the bases loaded for justin
turner who hit the first grand slam of
his career
in last night's game
[Applause]
smith has bets it third muncie at second
turner at first
dodgers within two in the eighth on a
2-2
will smith takes inside in fact it hits
him
it's 4-3 as smith gets pumped for
they're still loaded there's one out
there's an all-star at the plate
first-time all-star chris taylor field
on comes
the game is tied
[Applause]
a chance to win it muncie this year 369
with runners in scoring position
2-1 look to deep right field
they don't even move it's long gone
it's over a walk off for muncie
or they flip this one upside down and
then the first half
with a comeback win